okay now question why doesn't it say
this it's a real question have a think
about it
why is it that actually everyone knows
what to do with this without that being
there Erica what do you think we're
trying to put as little information as
possible on here we don't want extra
redundant information well this is
something that's only in exes and then
you're being told integrate with respect
to X right so clearly these boundaries
must be expounder YZ does that make
sense however and this is really
important for what we're about to do
today and I actually want you to write
this on the next line that you know
labeling of those boundaries is actually
implied we don't need to write it
because everyone knows where the 3 and
the 4 are going to go but it's actually
there it's kind of hiding just like when
you have you know something like this
there's a multiplication sign hiding
between the 5 and the bracket but we
kind of assume that we don't have to
write it so you know but it's implied so
it's important ok now we're under the
heading of integration by substitution
we met this earlier but I intentionally
told you back then I'm not telling you
everything because I don't want your
brains just to melt into a mess in the
first lesson on this topic ok but now
it's time to have a look at how this is
different to the previous ones you've
had a look at and it's all to do with
these boundaries right now how would I
do this by substitution this particular
question and an extension one you'll be
given the substitution where it's
required is let u equal now before I
give it to you take a guess what do you
think
it's probably gonna be the X -3 right
whatever is under here now you will be
supplied with one but it's not that hard
to guess what it might because this is
the problem right if I can let that
equal that then I'll be able to get rid
of that thing underneath the square root
okay what do I usually do at this point
you've done integration by substitution
in a couple of times what has to be done
with this okay I want to differentiate
because this is currently integrating
with respect to X but I'm going to get
it to be with respect to you so let's do
that
what is do you on DX in this case just
one because it just comes from this
right so in this context it's okay for
me to write that D U is actually the
same as DX you see that if I treat it as
a fraction in this context okay so I can
when I'm ready I can just swap this out
okay
to be weird though usually there's like
something else flying around and I want
to get rid of all of the X's not just
some of them I can get rid of this yeah
I can get rid of this how do I get rid
of this I don't want it to be an X there
I need everything to be used
hmm this is a really interesting spot
I'm not to show you and when you see it
you'll be like ah of course but this is
a really important moment so I'm about
to show you something that is leading ly
obvious there's no working to do really
okay but if you can't see it yet how are
you going to get there
okay Michael what do you think
we're searching for an X right we have
an X it's right there no differentiation
required to get to just the next as
Michael suggested if you just go
straight from this line and just add
three both sides you get that are you
okay with that so that's going to get
rid of this everything is fine okay let
me take this off maybe if you have
another color you can do it with me
I know how to get rid of this it's going
to be do you I know how to get rid of
this it's you and I just worked out how
to get rid of this it's you plus three
okay but can you see why I made a point
about these things and these things
right these are also in terms of X so I
need to get rid of these as well if x
equals four if x equals four what should
you be it should just be one because it
before take away three right so when x
equals four just put this over here on
the right hand side when x equals four
that makes you equal to one and by the
same logic when x equals three that's
the other boundary that's why I'm
choosing this number U is equal to zero
yeah three minus three so now it's not
just this piece and this piece and this
piece I can also get rid of these two
pieces now I'm actually ready to
substance you does that make sense so
it's just one extra step but you need to
learn to watch for it I'm going to leave
all this stuff here because that's part
of my working for this particular
question I've done all this pre work so
I can get rid of all the X's all at once
I can I'm gonna encourage you not to try
and mix up the using the X's because
otherwise you know usually you write it
like this and then you're like which
which boundaries are they in are they XS
or use do it all on one hit so there's
no ambiguity equals integral from what
to what have a look at the new
boundaries which way around is it be
careful it looks to me like three to
four will become zero to one okay now
just a quick note you're going to
encounter questions in a minute where
that won't be the case you'll actually
have to create an integral from 1 to Z
that's a bit strange okay but if you
won't go back to our moats on properties
of identity integrals or ask me a
question I can explain what that means
in this case it's fine it's ascending
I'm gonna get rid of the X what is it
it's you plus three I'm gonna get rid of
the X minus three that's just you and DX
I can just swap shape oppressor okay so
this is really good
everything's been translated we're still
not quite out of the woods yet though
because I have no idea what this is like
what what is this form it's a lot of
form that I recognize so what could I do
with this that might make it a little
easier to work with I can just expand
car tire this is U to the power of 1/2
this is U to the power of 1 so when I
multiply those I'm going to get U to the
power of 3 unto when I multiply this I'm
going to get 3 to the power of sorry u ^
it's just the square root of U right so
it's 1/2 is that okay now we can
integrate it so what are we going to get
here you to the power of 3 onto powers
going to now become 5 onto and I want to
divide by that so I'm gonna get this is
that okay in the past when I was first
doing this I would have written this as
an awkward fraction I'd go you to the
power of that and then I divide by that
but as you become more familiar with it
you can say all just dividing by a
fraction is multiplying by its
reciprocal okay so that's fine this is
going to become 3 over 2 when you divide
by 3 / - what's this become so if at
this point you are not sure that's a
signal to you that you should write it
like so right if you're not sure then
don't don't try and do the mental and
written take and get it wrong do it like
this but then do you see what's gonna
happen this is gonna happen right cancel
cancel you're dividing by 1/2 which is
the same as multiplying by 2 Zadok
okay so if you if you're in doubt then
um then actually go ahead and write the
fraction even if it's awkward you'll get
right where'd your substitute down so
let's do it I'm gonna get two fifths
plus two
I'll just put one in there yep take away
what's the law boundary in this case as
commonly its 0 ok 2 and 2/5 happy times
okay so let's just rewind a second come
back all the way over here when you go
given this substitution remember to use
it to get rid of everything I like
writing this to give me a reminder that
that 3 and that 4 also needs to be
replaced just like everything else okay
once you've done all your pre work okay
replace everything in one hit and then
treat it just like any other integral
that you normally would make sense